[موسيقى]
ليست هذه هي المرة الأولى ،
وربما لا يتم الحفر في غزة الأخيرة ،
فقد انتهى الأمر في الوقت الحالي ، وسيتم
إزالة الأنقاض وربما تم إصلاح الضرر ،
لكن كارثة من صنع الإنسان تلو
الأخرى
تسببت في خسائر فادحة في مكان
ليس بعيدًا عن الجدران  فصل غزة
عن
أطفال إسرائيل من عائلة أختار الممتدة
بحثا عن آثار
لخالتها المحطمة وثلاثة أطفال سحقوا حتى
الموت عندما سقطت قنبلة
على منزلها لأن
القصف من حولنا
كان مكثفًا وسقطت علينا الأبواب والنوافذ.
الغرفة الداخلية التي تتذكر
أن القنبلة الأخيرة كانت في هذا المنزل
، تمكنت أسماء من الزحف لتحرير الناس
في هذه المنطقة من
المزارعين في الغالب ، لكنهم غالبًا ما
يستخدمونها من قبل المسلحين لإطلاق الصواريخ على
إسرائيل
في مستشفى أودي
التجميلي والترميمي.
يجري واحدة من ثماني
عمليات جراحية في هذا اليوم سافر لأول مرة
إلى غزة عندما كان طالبًا شابًا في الطب
في الثمانينيات
وعاد بانتظام منذ
مهمته هنا.
تنتهي ، تبدأ في الوقوع في
مرضى
مصابين في هجمات متعددة ،
لذا فقد كان لدي مرضى أصيبوا بجروح في
حرب 2014
ثم أصيبوا في
مسيرات العودة الكبرى
أو أصيبوا في صراعات أه سابقة
ثم مرة أخرى في هذا
الصراع وهكذا أنت  أصبح نوعًا ما
مثل مرض متوطن
إصابات الحرب تصبح مثل مرض مستوطن
في غزة
في حي الشيخ زايد
ينتظر شاحنة لنقل أثاثه
بعيدًا ،
لا يزال منزله سليمًا بعد أن
دمرت القنابل المباني المجاورة مباشرة
ولكنه الآن في  خطر الانهيار ،
كافح سيزيف لدفع الصخرة
إلى أعلى التل
فقط لكي تتدحرج إلى القاع
فقط لتدفعها مرة أخرى مرة أخرى.
لا يوجد
خيار آخر علينا أن نستمر في العيش ، علينا
إعادة بنائه مرارًا وتكرارًا
حتى يومًا ما ، ربما يمكننا أن نكون أحرارًا
في غياب نوع من
الحل ،
مثل دهون غزة  ه بن ويتمان cnn
غزة
لك